[Música]
el paisaje es espectacular
pero caminar por la selva aquí en el
tapón del Darién en la frontera de
Colombia con Panamá no es un paseo
es un gran reto para los migrantes
y venenosa te pica te mueres con esa
culebra es tan serpenteando a través de
100 km de Selva muy duro difícil está
rota
estos hombres mujeres y niños emprenden
el viaje porque creen que tienen poco
más que perder
los migrantes ayudan unos a otros a
medida que avanzan
impulsados por el sueño de llegar a
Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]
Esta es su historia
A las 6 de la mañana del primer día se
reunieron en este campamento al borde de
la selva dirigido por un colombiano
narcotraficante
y recibieron las últimas instrucciones
antes de partir
porque se creen que no que más Superman
no es la que estén embarazadas tengan
mucho tiempo hablen me están pariendo en
el camino uno están perdiendo los bebés
entre los que emprenden el viaje
Fernanda y su hija
y Manuel son de Ecuador y se hicieron
amigos en un barco hacia Colombia son
conscientes de los riesgos que hay
cocodrilos y que vamos a ver en el
camino muertos Sí hay una fractura de
pierna te cambia todo el viaje Entonces
eso y de aquí para allá o para acá no te
pueden auxiliar que ya estamos un poco
debilitados anímicamente la reserva se
acaban
el grupo de cientos de migrantes
comienza lo que es un maratón agotador
que durará días
la carretera Panamericana va desde el
extremo norte de Alaska hasta el extremo
sur de América
más de 25.000 kilómetros de carretera
excepto en el tapón del Darién que une
Suramérica con Centroamérica
no hay carretera durante 106 kilómetros
en su lugar solo hay selva
los migrantes han pagado 350 dólares
cada uno al cartel para hacer el viaje
una cantidad enorme para estas personas
que ya han recorrido un largo camino
para llegar a este punto
de Haití
a Chile
muy fácil uno caminan 10 horas al día
Fernanda está luchando
y Manuel también pero siguen tan
decididos como siempre yo tengo que
avanzar porque no puedo volver por
la por los problemas que hay ahora en el
país No dice más en este momento
al tercer día llegan a la frontera de
Colombia con Panamá
Aquí no hay aduana solo un cartel
pero bien Vamos avanzando hasta con el
tiempo muy bien
vamos para seguir adelante
esa noche explicó Por qué se fue de
Ecuador
me cortó los brazos Me ahorcó quiso
matarme y él quería seguirme buscando
para O sea que quiere matarme y ella me
dio la decisión mami Vámonos mami
Vámonos tenía unas pocas cosas en mi
casa como televisión de
electrodomésticos ya y los vendimos
Manuel también se sinceró dice que huyó
de Ecuador porque una banda de
narcotraficantes quería reclutarlo y él
se negó sacaron mi casa
en el cual en ese ataque falleció mi
esposa
mi niño que estaba en estado y una
persona Un conocido un amigo que estaba
en ese momento en
tienen tres días más por delante para
llegar a Panamá
tienen que cruzar arroyos y ríos y por
el camino ven cadáveres de migrantes que
han muerto de cansancio
el cartel ya no tiene el control Aquí
mandan los bandidos
ven El cadáver de una mujer violada y el
cuerpo de un hombre que según los
Testigos fue arrojado desde el
acantilado
el viaje continúa con la esperanza de
que puedan salir ilesos
cerca del final se encuentran con una
mujer abandonada por un grupo delante de
ellos
está embarazada y no puede caminar bien
tras torcerse el tobillo
algunos de los migrantes haitianos
construyeron una camilla para ella
el viaje en total dura 5 días a pie y un
tramo al final en Canoa para llegar al
primer pueblo en Panamá
lo han conseguido sin embargo no ha
terminado
les quedan otros 3.000 kilómetros por
recorrer a través de Centroamérica
[Aplausos]